prochain arrêt information et prévention
sur les accidents vasculaires cérébraux
c'est la mission du bus avc qui a
parcouru les yvelines durant le mois de
novembre et de décembre
organisé par la rs et france avc ile de
france cette action a été menée à
montigny le bretonneux
mais vaut mieux être préparé à avoir les
bons réflexes et les bons gestes pour
intervenir rapidement et espérer s'en
sortir sont sans trop de séquelles
ça m'a semblé intéressant la fois de
venir pour rafraîchir un peu les
connaissances sur les causes les
symptômes et en même temps avoir un
bilan de cas d'avc sont possibles une
artère bouchée ou une rupture
plusieurs facteurs de risque
l'hypertension artérielle l'arythmie
cardiaque le diabète ou le cholestérol
un dépistage de ces situations a été mis
en place à l'intérieur du bus limité
l'avc ses limites et des facteurs de
risque donc les dépister et les
contrôler c'est aussi peut-être avoir
une vie une vie plus saine et on va
aussi rechercher des rétrécissements
artérielle que qui peuvent survenir au
niveau des artères carotides en
utilisant un écho doppler un avc c'est
la paralysie d'un bras ou d'une jambe un
engourdissement d'un bras ou d'une jambe
perte de la vue difficultés pour parler
la bouche de travers voilà ce sont les
principaux signes de l'avc est là il
faut faire une seule chose il faut
appeler le 15
le traitement doit être administré
rapidement pour les personnes victimes
d'avc avec de lourdes séquelles
l'association france avc organise des
ateliers
objectif leur redonner de l'autonomie
lors de l'hospitalisation et des trois
mois suivants 12 % des victimes décèdent
60% n'auront que des séquelles mineurs